-You know why everyone's
in a good mood?
I want to wish everyone
a happy National Beer Day,
everybody.
-Whoa!
-That's today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
National --
Today is National Beer Day,
or as we called it growing up,
Father's Day.
[ Laughter ]
"Give me another one."
Let's get to some important,
happy, and historic news.
Today, the Senate officially
confirmed Ketanji Brown Jackson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Making her the first Black woman
on the Supreme Court.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
It's great.
That's right. She's going to be
Justice Jackson.
Yeah,
when Disney heard that name,
they immediately added her to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Jackson will now debate
the most important issues
facing our country,
like freedom of speech,
states' rights,
and "is it cake?"
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this is cool.
Jackson actually watched
the Senate confirmation vote
live with President Biden
at the White House.
Here they are, here's a picture.
Yeah.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
Looks less like
a Supreme Court confirmation,
more like a Zoom wedding.
Doesn't it, a little bit?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It's also an exciting time
in the sports world,
'cause it was opening day of
Major League Baseball season
and the first day of
the Masters golf tournament.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All today.
Yep.
Baseball and golf --
it's basically the Olympics
for napping in front of the TV.
[ Laughter ]
But the big story at the Masters
is that Tiger Woods is back
and playing great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How annoying is that
for everyone else?
-Yeah.
-The guy misses 17 months,
he comes back, he's like,
"Well, I guess I'll just go
win the Masters, I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Well, some business news --
I read that Richard Branson
wants to swap rockets
with Elon Musk.
[ Laughter ]
So that he can fly to space
with SpaceX,
and Musk can fly
with Virgin Galactic.
[ Laughter ]
So I guess Kimmel and I
really started a trend, right?
[ Laughter ]
Usually when two guys want
to try out each other's rockets,
we can't talk about it on TV.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I saw that the CEO
of Red Lobster has resigned
after just eight months
on the job.
Now Red Lobster
has to pick a new CEO
out of the live CEO tank.
[ Laughter ]
"That one.
That one's perfect."
It's odd.
Usually the only thing
that hangs around Red Lobster
for eight months
is the coconut shrimp.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, people
are talking about this.
The FDA is looking into
complaints all over the country
from people getting sick
from Lucky Charms.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
The FDA was like, "Well,
here's your first problem --
you're eating marshmallows
for breakfast, so..."
[ Laughter ]
So far, the symptoms are
[ Irish accent ] "pink eyes,
green tongue, and yellow skin."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Some TV news.
A lot of people are talking
about Ken Burns'
new Ben Franklin documentary
on PBS.
Have you seen it?
He's made over 20 documentaries,
but, I don't -- maybe he's
doing it for too long.
I think he might be losing it.
I just felt --
I feel like the -- something --
The writing's off.
I don't know.
Take a look at what I saw.
♪♪
-Mm. Hot.
Oh!
John Adams.
Would you like some tea?
-Don't mind if I brew?
[ Both laugh ]
[ Slide whistle plays ]
-And by the way,
have you seen my kite?
-As if. You're never
getting that thing back.
-What about the electricity?
-Benjamin Franklin,
I don't have all day.
I have to go back
to see my family.
-What family?
-Why, the Adams family.
[ "Addams Family" theme plays ]
That's my last name.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
I concur.
-I found it odd.
Well, this is interesting.
Researchers in Japan
created a --
[ Laughter ]
What's the problem?
-I'm just -- I don't --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what
that was supposed to be.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think you saw?
-I thought I saw...
-Yeah?
-...Benjamin Franklin...
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Hey, okay.
-...John Adams...
-That's correct.
-...chatting by a modern-day
coffee station.
-Yeah, like a -- like a Keurig,
or something.
-Right? They're drinking
in demitasse cups.
-Yes.
-He drank his coffee --
-He's like...
-First of all, it's so hot
that he had to go,
"Ouch, ouch, ouch."
-He said, "Hot."
-"Hot."
And then John Adams drank it,
and his eyes went --
whoop! -- like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It was a little --
-That was -- Ken Burns did that.
-Ken Burns
apparently did that, yeah.
-Wow! You're right --
the writing is off.
-I just --
Something's off, right?
-Yeah, something's off.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there's no actual footage
of Ben Franklin,
so they had to re-create it.
-Yeah, right.
-So I guess, let him --
let him improvise.
-You know what?
That explains it all.
You have to improvise.
'Cause you don't know.
You weren't there.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this is interesting,
guys.
I think you'll find this
interesting.
In Japan, these researchers
created a robot
that mastered
a pretty important task.
Check this out.
[ Laughter ]
-It's great if you feel like
eating a banana next week.
It really is.
People wonder why it's taking
so long to beat COVID, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
A driver in Maine
had to be rescued after she made
a wrong turn at a garbage dump
and ended up
on top of a trash compacter.
This is real.
Look at this.
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Yet another success story
for Apple Maps.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, happy National Beer Day,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]